belle a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono by j e oggi
siamo ritornati ma una luce particolare
da fare un paio di settimane fa sono
andato a londra perché nintendo che ha
invitato a provare il nuovo pokémon
pokémon si chiude con una spada
ho provato pokémon spada perché io sono
team pata ho bloccato un pochettino la
giornata ovviamente non posso mettermi
hotel del gioco e sono più privati
dell'area 51 nel mentre vi lascio con la
mia experience a londra e poi passiamo
nel video normale
let's go del rigo ci sono questi media
giochi praticamente fatti girare ci
vuole una suite gigantesca che
precederanno non so come la porterò in
aereo e teoricamente lì dentro verrà la
magia mi faranno provare pokémon scudo e
spada là dentro però non posso
riprendere niente trovi dico sebbene
ragazzi ho fatto la partita
ho giocato 90 minuti dove il gioco non
era una demo era un gioco vero però che
non potevo andare avanti in più di un
tot però veramente figo forse incontro a
new day quando uscirà comunque veramente
carino ragazzi e ragazze aspettate un
attimo fermi non so se posso mettermi
questa clip
ma veramente lo stesso ma al massimo mi
arrestano
comunque ragazzi in sintesi mi è
piaciuto un sacco e non vedo l'ora di
provarlo quando non riuscirà diciamo che
c'è una motivazione del perché io ho
scelto spada invece che escludo perché
il leggendario di spada per questo vado
nei giganti in bocca e devo cercare di
capire durante la trama del gioco quando
quando ci giocherò se effettivamente può
appoggiarla per terra ogni tanto quindi
questa cosa qua mi preme molto saperlo
quindi giocherò appunto a spada in una
scudo per questo motivo ma comunque mi
faccio dare un paio di robe perché
quest'anno facendo una foto punti cacio
gigantesco posso fare la foto colpi che
ho fatto la foto ragazzi adesso vi
faccio una ripresa un po velocissima di
quello velocissimo non è italiano ma chi
se ne frega il tutto quello che si sa se
questo incredibile scaffale cioè
incredibile mi sembra di stare nella
stanza di della sabri gamer veramente
figo soprattutto inter comunque si
ragazzi ringrazio nintendo perché sono
qua a londra grazie a loro mi ha fatto
provare gio ven anteprima che sono
raccomandato e gioco uscirà il 15
novembre 15 novembre a come per me
lombok siamo è andato mi ha regalato
delle robe ragazzi però non possiamo
abbozzare qua ora vi faccio vedere una
roba che nella mia infanzia bordi voleva
dire tanto ci voleva dire avere le
ragazzine vicino cioè le carte piguet
quando ero piccolo queste carte erano
non so spiegarmi come avere un rolex al
polso
soprattutto questa qui era la mia carta
preferita in assoluto se ne avete una
ricordatevi che esistono ho trovato il
tavolo giusto sul quale fare l'unboxing
l'ho trovato e qua fuori dalla the
pokémon company cioè direttamente questo
tavolo che è utilizzato grafico ma lei
detto dove sei o no andrà a londra andrà
ovviamente ci hanno dato non lo so cosa
ci si vuol dire in creme possa già
stropicciato firmato da lui ma notai
firmato ma veramente e lei è riuscita a
strappi ciarlo da masuda e firma il suo
vero poi ci hanno dato dei mazzi di
carte di pokémon addirittura in italiano
perché sapevano anche ad aragon italiana
era già andato italiano e non solo
adesso vi faccio vedere stavo perdendo
ma tutta questa gara ce n'è ancora una
queste beppe con packaging ante
incredibile mi hanno dato un po di carte
oggi ragazzo per un po poi dire che
raduni posso non portarle che le gambe
ai ragazzi guardatevi il gameplay che
per fortuna non è più in congo
benvenuti su e ciò pur tempo non trovo
la risposta non lo sto parlando di te un
gioco si chiama così praticamente quando
tu parti in questo gioco credo sia un
ambiente horror perché ho visto negli
screen che una roba molto horror e gente
non so becco lo qua c'è questa comprende
una schermata veramente [ __ ]
c'è un folletto salve lei e pippi
calzelunghe o qualcosa del genere cos'è
ma sono io che mi comando ai pensavo di
essere quello che guardava la cosa
invece non sono io io sono il folletto
vabbè mi scusi non volevo bellissimo
dunque la fisica è fatta da dior srt
shift su internet
ok bellissimo come spinge la porta
malissimo alla stessa verve più o meno
di insight sono molto più colorato
l'inside bronzo rondò aspetta che non so
come si rispetta economy spiega cosa
devo fare in sto gioco qua che ancora
non ho capito che devo aprire le porte
porca vacca c'è un ancora in casa si è
fermata l'ombra anno l'ombra va
l'opposto che non è un'ombra è un
riflesso riflesso va all'opposto di dove
vado io
cioè io vedo un pupazzo quale le vedono
ancora va bene vado di là bas perché c'è
una tenda la apro apro la tenda non apro
la tenda va bene in jpg spingi spingi
bravo sembra ecco sempre l'incrocio tra
inside and unknown the sleep ragazzi lo
ricordate l'on the sleep uguale
l'ambientazione molto simile molto figo
sei un horror che improntano c'è la ci
sono delle dell'acqua c'è un ascensore
qui prendo l'ascensore
salve sono contento che lei è il mio
riflesso però non obbliga a fare qui a
deve attivare tutte e due le leve ok
prendila che grazie io sfrutto i
riflessi per farvi del ben 91 che
incredibile suo gioco fatto di fatto
benissimo non vedo a c'è la scatola del
riflesso butta misura schepp buttame
laggiù la scatola buttame la giunta
buttavi bravo bravo butta vigila scafo
bravissimo esattamente quello che volevo
perché dall'altro c'è una sedia a
rotelle in mezzo all'acqua li sapete che
cosa mi dispiace disco gioco ragazzi che
purtroppo c'è un'ambulanza
va bene siamo usciti comunque sono fuori
dal demonio sono io sono morto bug nome
qual è il mio riflesso quello che sta
nell'acqua prima no piace scusami non ho
capito
dicevo sapete che cos'è che mi dispiace
è che è una sorta di demo quindi non c'è
un gioco pieno che posso fare ad episodi
peccato perché sembra fatto da dio sedia
rotelle reception
siamo in un ospedale
io in realtà sono la bambina con la che
è morta ma sto rivivendo tutto dal mio
subito quindi io sono il mio subconscio
non so sto provando a fare delle foto
kafkiana questa trama posso entrare qui
dentro perfetto sono nella reception
cerimonio riflesso
non c'è il riflesso perché è morto a no
ecologia tira con la mano
prendila anche da sopra prendete tutte e
due fatevi forza entrambi che bravo
bravo
una gonna guarda se fossi maurizio
merluzzo ce la farei senza riflesso però
suicida ma mi si sta aprendo la porta ma
con avevo visto non ho ben capito sono
vere riflessi sento dei bip
qualcuno sta per morire sono io che sono
morto
[Risate]
u sacrosanti gesù cristo non ho capito
pesa un giga sto gioco è finito come
possibili ma come come come possibile e
philippe nova fermi non hanno capito è
finito per la cosa ma pesa un giga
no ragazzi non ho capito come fa essere
già pesa un giga perché fatto da dio
cioè però era è un livello non era
neanche il tutorial c'è proprio era era
un experience porca vacca me durato
pochissimo e corto il gioco ragazzi
spero di di capire almeno la trama il
gioco corto alla reyer una bambina uno
della mia famiglia ha preso il telefono
e ha chiamato l'ambulanza perché sono
annegata nella in casa uso quindi mi
hanno portato in rianimazione
all'ospedale hanno tentato di rianimarli
sul lettino alla fine sono sono morta
questo è quello che è successo
secondo la mia mente credo sia bello
bello e bellissimo po strano vabbè
ragazzi questo era e ciò molto bello mi
è piaciuto per quanto fosse veramente
corto ma bellissimo mi è proprio
piaciuto
speriamo ci facciano un gioco pieno
perché cavolo beh bellissimo concept
giuro quindi ragazzo però vide vi sia
piaciuto quasi sempre più l'argomento vi
piace anche per i social con il tutto
descrizione e noi come sempre ci
rivediamo a un prossimo video bella
ragazzi